well this is an interesting question
that without offending a lot of chefs
that I know you know every chef is going
to borrow something from someone else
and it's about I mean just like i said
before like if i go to Oaxaca and I have
you know some chicken mole a that I mean
I might not have the recipe from it but
you know the balance between all the
ingredients oven I'm going to remember
what they are and I might you know
reproduce that in some way even though
it's not like a chef or a recipe or even
a technique it's just a flavor you know
and there's definitely things that the
chef's that I've worked for before you
know you take that so that's how you be
that's how you get a cooking voice
really it's about collecting but I
always think to myself is this a Daniel
Boulud ish because if it is i'm getting
rid of it not because it won't be good
it just because i just don't want to do
that you know are my grandma's
grandmother's ravioli is that some
culinary revolution that was never done
before absolutely not but as it is
interesting about culinary trends and
proprietary stuff and because I've gone
back and forth through Europe over many
years and if eaten a lot of places
there's a lot of Chef barring that's
gone on over the years that never gets
checked by the media because not
everyone really knows about it and
there's lots of instances I see still
see it all the time I mean I'm n what
I've been to el bulli three times now
and there was a particular dish that he
did it was probably like four years ago
it was the apple caviar technique which
was uh it was when he started really
consult chemists and he was he made this
it looked like caviar but it tasted like
green apples and I had that and it was
like June it was like when you first
opened like beginning of the season
that was a dish that they had introduced
that year and they came back to New York
and about a month later I ate at a
restaurant in Manhattan and there was a
pineapple caviar on you know the menu
already in a matter of it was a month
really there was a dish that I had in
San Francisco probably 12 years ago it
was a lobster dish then at probably one
of the better restaurants in San
Francisco and I thought it was great
then I went to go work at a restaurant
in Paris for six months and it was their
signature dish likely chef's signature
dish I saw on the TV Food Network I saw
a chef that you might know doing his
famous potato crusted sea bass which
Daniel Balu was doing Atlas zurich in
1986 but Danielle to his credit and even
his cookbook you know and he says where
he got the inspiration for that dish he
attributed attributed to Roger averages
potato-crusted rouget and he just
adapted it in a way to an American fish
and changed the shape and a little bit
but he still gave you know some credit
where credit was due and that I always
thought was with respect
I was cool
you